I've been looking and laughing and thinking and dreaming
Is that a VOD?
Breakthrowing?
Oh!
Mm-mm
Also me.
Hmm, why are all my VODs getting limited?
Ah!
It's almost like I'm saying nothing wrong with that talk.
Right?
I get it, get it.
Alright, hate, hate the background first!
Hate the background.
Right.
I don't want to show you the background.
We must first analyze...
the collapse.
The collapse?
The streams.
Whoa, is there some honkers on screen right now?
Have we puke enough?
Maybe she'll see the glow?
No!
I mean, don't stop puking.
Weeping!
Stop puking!
Fifteen minutes was my life.
I told you I was gonna be late.
Whoa!
Fifteen minutes was my life.
Pfft!
No, you didn't just hear that feedback loop.
Stop it!
Moonman!
Reflect!
Good morning, good evening.
Good afternoon!
How's it going?
How's it to mommies?
Infinite mommies, literally an infinite mommies.
How's it going?
We just did a meeting.
Sorry, I was a little late.
I'm a big girl.
I did a meeting.
That's just so narrow.
Good afternoon!
I'm sorry, I'm late.
Okay, let's go through...
this schedule.
But first...
let me point a few things out.
Today we're doing the questionnaire stream.
And then we're gonna watch the Kingsman after.
If you haven't seen the Kingsman.
Oh, Reflect!
Reflect!
Go back to pointing at the call of the...
Move!
Why are you stuck at...
Reflect?
What are you doing, young man?
Move!
Thank you, good reflect.
Right, we're doing call of the lamb tomorrow.
Now, call of the lamb...
Call of the lamb.
I have played it before.
And when you defeat the boss,
they put you on a section after.
I don't think I'm gonna do the section after
because it's very repetitive gameplay.
So we might finish call of the lamb in one goal?
Question mark!
And then this will change into a different thing.
Maybe script writing or something of that nature.
You know, something...
because Azura has given me permission to write her...
Donathon scripts.
If you were...
I'm just gonna leave you down there.
If you were very kind and had the opportunity
and the income for donating, tipping, supporting Azura,
the management has sent you an email asking for
either a screen name or your name.
And you will...
Azura is gonna start preparing your reward, okay?
So do check your emails that you may have used for stream elements.
Why are you getting so big?
You had a bone bone.
He's getting bigger.
I've got Kill It With Fire 2 collab with Emmers
and Juna and Fuyo.
But that's not how you say it.
And I got members A, some R after it.
And then it's time to lose IQ
and become the same smartness that I have.
We're gonna play Overwatch 2.
And I'm gonna play Juna and Tank.
And I'm gonna try and see if Zarya is even viable anymore
or Reinhardt, but I don't think they are.
I don't know what the state of Overwatch is,
but you're losing brain cells with me on Friday.
Now, I said two hours later, I'm gonna do a drawn stream, but...
I don't know.
I may get addicted to Overwatch.
Should I picked Mercy?
Should I picked Juna, apparently?
And then after however long it takes us to wrap it up on Overwatch,
I'm doing a members drawing you
and I'm going to give you a new gamer tag.
I don't know how to do it fairly.
I think we're gonna have to take a few stabs at this stream
to make sure everyone gets one.
But just give me some time, okay?
Does anybody know how to do that, man?
I'm trying my best.
Zarya was pretty broken coming out.
I don't think it's changed that.
Then we do a 20k celebration stream,
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
which is gonna be one hour of ring fit.
And then it's not one hour of being in a shower,
but I'm gonna make sure the audio isn't blowing the fuck out this time
because it was blowing out last time.
Basically, I'm gonna make it an ASMR stream
and try and do stuff as quiet as possible.
So basically, you're drifting again.
Base...
Ah, just leave it here.
Basically, I'm gonna try and be quietly doing ring fit.
I don't even know if that's possible.
Oh, don't read this part yet.
Don't read this part yet.
Don't read this bottom bit
that you're currently covering with your butt.
Don't read that part yet, okay?
That's part of the stream.
Okay?
Then we're gonna do members1v1 on chess.com.
So if you've not got a chess.com account,
you better get one
because I don't have one either.
I need to make it.
I need to make it and then do a test.
So I think I'm gonna ask...
I'm gonna see if Sin will take the time to make a chess.com account
so we can snipe each other and be like,
there's no IP leakage, right?
But I don't think there is
because I'm pretty sure like the top chess players
play against each other.
And then just to end the week,
we're just gonna do a nice casual gas station simulator.
Depending on how that goes,
it might do another script writing stream.
I do have a wee bit of work up ahead of me,
but nothing that we can't handle together.
Refling, huh?
But yeah, pretty jam-packed week.
As I said, call it the run part two.
If we kind of speedrun part one,
we might actually just wrap it up
or wrap it up and do something new on this day.
I'm not sure what, but...
Look, I'll figure it out.
God, you really like that position.
Right.
But yeah, that's the agendination.
Everything starts at the usual time slot.
There's no...
There's no moving around.
Fuyu and Juno were very kind to agree to my time slot.
I don't know how I convinced all of them.
Do you want to stream at this time?
Supermarket together.
Wait, you can stream snipe in a supermarket?
What do you mean by draw and stream?
You draw the profile picture?
No, I'm gonna draw...
I'm gonna give you a new gamer tag
and then draw your gamer tag.
Yes, I have brain rot.
No, I will not explain further.
Don't shame us.
It's a comfy spot.
Your art got quite the buffastee.
Bro, literally.
Special shout out to Stressos.
Fuck, I can't read that.
I'm not gonna put my glasses on.
Stressos.
Stressos gave me titties.
Wow, Refling.
Not in public.
Google supermarket together.
Wait, real and true.
Supermarket together.
Together.
No, we can run a supermarket together.
Oh, you'll never guess why it's called supermarket together.
You'll never guess why it's called supermarket together.
Hee hee hee hee hee.
Day five of Earth.
Do you not send in marshmallows?
Bruh, to the person that sent me a marshmallow of sheebie farting.
Count your fucking days.
I was heehawing into my cup of tea, okay?
I was heehawing into my cup of tea.
I'm like, oh, I've got one new marshmallow since I went to sleep.
I'll wake up and it's a clip of sheebie farting.
And you know the worst part?
I sent it in a marshmallow, yes.
You know the worst part?
I can see your name.
Who clipped it?
I know who you are.
Creeping around, clipping the farts of my daughters.
I see your name when you clip it.
You are not, you are not hidden.
You might have sent it anonymously on marshmallow, but I see who you are.
So I'm looking out for your name.
I know who you are.
Cotton 4K.
Exactly.
Right, anyway, that's the agendination.
I did not put it in yesterday's stream.
I just want to say I apologize for yesterday's stream.
I was cooked beyond belief in the negative sense and the well-done steak sense of the
H, C, B, A, L, M, N, O, P, E thing.
I unfortunately got one hour of sleep before that stream.
It was a Christmas miracle.
I was coherent enough to read the script, okay?
So there you go.
The name derisling.
No, no, Derisling didn't operate with enough ops.
Wait, you can see who clips?
Yes, I can see who clips.
You didn't know that?
I can see what you call the clips as well of me.
Some people clip when I say their name, like their actual name, like when I'm like,
congrats, Alex, because that's a common name, congrats, Mason.
I can see that.
I'm coming for you.
I'm putting together who you are.
It's okay, mommy.
At least you slept before stream, right?
I slept three times yesterday.
So I passed out for six hours after stream.
I went to the shops and got chicken and fed my magpie.
I then slept for a further like four hours and then I slept four hours before this stream,
but I woke up two hours earlier to do the mean.
You're coming for a clip.
Her name's Sus, literally.
She's making a list and checking.
I'm making a list.
I'm checking it twice.
I'm trying to see.
Have it milk this three times.
Thank you.
Strony has a magpie as a pet.
Wild magpies, but they're tame to me.
It's a boy magpie.
I'm trying to hand feed him at this point in time.
I almost hand fed him with chicken.
I had to look away.
I wasn't allowed to look at him.
So I was like holding my hand out and I was looking away and I was like, no, no, no.
I'm not looking at you.
Take it from my hand.
But we're getting really close.
Mail mentioned on through a fucking magpie.
Right.
I said you're done though.
So this stream is a fever dream.
I have.
I'm going to be honest.
I made this when I was completely delirious.
So I am going to be as surprised as you are when we go into the stream.
Okay.
I'm not surprised as you are.
So what is this stream even about your Raj?
Your Raj means like you mental person.
And then this is you thinking going, hmm, oh wait, hold on a minute.
Is this too big?
I think it is.
Hold on.
Let him get up.
Yeah, this is too big.
You're so big.
Okay.
I mean, I made myself smaller, but I'll go here.
All right.
That looks good.
That looks good to me.
Point to me Flynn.
Got it.
So we're about to find out how delirious I was making this because I really
actually don't.
So I have sound effects that go along with this that I put together.
I have no idea if this is going to work or not.
So yeah.
Will this be a peek into Mummy's mind?
Yes.
So get ready to tally your marks because points are awarded.
Okay.
So just to start off, it's a fun Z stream where I ask you questions about
myself and you are awarded points at the end of the stream.
There's going to be a tier list to see how corrupted you are.
And that's it.
And then I put IQ and love hearts here.
Apparently.
I don't know why notes.
This is for fun and please don't take it too seriously or to heart.
I am purposefully asking questions.
You might know the answer to or you would never know the answer to.
So you can't win.
Okay.
And go with your instincts.
Young padawan.
Use the force and force yourself inside.
Plop, plop, plop, plop, plop.
Okay.
Come on.
It's me.
Of course.
There's already a head.
I go to the next slide.
Can I just do this?
Nope.
I can't hold on.
Wait, hold on.
I'm sunlocked already.
Shit.
Okay.
Hey, there we go.
Right.
What is this?
And what?
No.
Okay.
I kind of remember in what situation did my frontal lobe develop?
And I realized I was very special and then this is my chicken breast smooth
brain here.
Okay.
When I complained about hating doing the dishes because my sleeves get
wet and then my mom told me to roll them up the random rain spots on the
pavement aren't from rain and it's actually dog piss or I couldn't cut
into the butter and my dad told me to microwave it and I almost nuked a knife
if he didn't stop me.
So just answer in your head and I will reveal.
I was convinced on the pavement.
It was random rain spots.
I was like, oh, that's really strange.
There was like a rain cloud that formed for a second.
You know?
Um, all three are low IQ.
Honestly, you ready?
Are you steady?
Boom.
Oh, I'm in the way.
Drat.
I'm in the way.
You get three points.
If it's rolling up my sleeves doing the dishes.
Okay.
It's three points.
That's when it clicked.
Okay.
I was like this entire time my sleeves have been getting wet and all I had to
do and I wasn't a child.
I I was.
Yeah.
I was not a child.
So three points.
Um, if it's about the dishes, one point, if it's the rain spots, that is true.
I figured out it was dog pee later on in life.
Um, and the butter story is also true.
I almost blew up my house.
So, um, so, you know, that was just my Irish roots showing.
Sorry.
So you still get a point if you've got the other ones because they're not all
wrong, but it definitely was the last one.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, speaking of nuking things.
Here's a microwave sound effect.
There you go.
That's it.
That's the microwave.
That's I don't, yes, I downloaded microwave sound effects.
Okay.
I don't know why I just thought it would add to the stream.
Have you got meat refling?
What would I pick?
Do I pick chicken?
Do I pick steak or do I pick fish and then is meat?
I guess.
I am really great.
Oh, I need to put my fanny down.
Sorry.
Hold on.
I need to cover up the old fanny.
I'm rather creative when I'm delirious because what is this?
Chicken.
Okay, you ready?
You steady?
Hold on.
I've lost the slide.
Shit.
Okay.
Damn, boy.
Were you just frying chicken in there?
For real though.
You kiss loud as fuck.
I think that's pretty cool.
That's my sound effect.
So if you, this is fucking delirious.
Holy crap.
Look at all the chick.
Why is there so much chicken on the screen?
Three points.
If you pick chicken.
Yeah.
Damn, boy.
You kiss loud as fuck.
No, seriously, were you frying chicken in there?
You get one point for steak even though you can't see it anymore because of iron.
I need to have a steak every month for iron and then you get zero for fish,
believe it or not, because battered haddock from Britain is the only thing I can tolerate.
I didn't like any other fish.
Um, even though I'm a cuttlefish and I eat other fish, you know what I'm saying?
So this is a picture of me thinking about eating fried chicken because it's the most delicious thing in the whole wide world.
Fried chicken, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding is the best.
I don't care.
Okay.
And then we go.
We go next.
Okay.
Are you ready?
What game have I not played before?
Half life to, and then there's a half life to logo, resident evil, any resident evil for logo for some reason, mass effect, any mass effect logo.
I'll give you a second to deliberate to master debate about what you think the answer is.
Okay.
What game have I not played?
I, the gamer of all gamers have not played.
Okay.
Are you ready?
Are you steady?
Oh, oh, get pranked.
You got pranked.
Get raked.
I've not played any of them.
You get three points for every, if you answered any of them, get pranked.
Keep calm.
You've been pranked.
Troll the low low low.
I haven't played any of them.
Okay.
Get raked.
You're raked.
I haven't played any of them.
Look all my little, God, I was fucking, I was so bad putting this together.
Okay.
But yeah, you get, you get three points.
Technically, if you said them all, I guess you can add three, but really it should just be three.
Yena?
So you got pranked.
So you're starting to think like me now.
Okay.
Now here's a good one.
Oh, wait.
Oh, hold on.
I just realized, if I move this over here, I'm like looking straight at you.
Okay.
This is better.
This is a better setup for me.
Okay.
Viola was based after voice acting approach to VTuber.
And since VTubers be voice acting in shits, you know, my special interests.
My advice constantly getting ignored when people, when people like beg me to raise them because they have ray gun bro.
Okay.
And also it's a microphone in the logo.
If you guys didn't know that, I don't know, I don't.
Oh, right.
Okay.
No.
Well, that was too early for that sound effect.
Hold on.
I was too early.
Premature misfire, misfire, bro.
Okay.
It's a Kuma project.
It's all for me.
I'm not even kidding.
Look at this.
No, seriously.
How did you let it get so successful?
What's going on?
I'm in the way of AC.
Hold on.
Hi.
I'm in the way of AC.
Look.
It's Kuma project and you let it get this successful.
Hello.
And now like, and then look, look, look, look, look, look broken.
Giant test.
Yandere officer Brad Farrell fucking.
And then this is unity and for some reason, look, I don't know if
you can see in the very top right left corner there.
That's the unity ammo and I was trying to stretch it to get bigger
and then I got really pixelated.
So there's just like pixel cuts of unity ammo everywhere.
I don't know what was going on.
I was like, I was trying my best.
I'm just like, I'm just having to be here.
Yeah.
A little tiny pot twist.
The rest of the girls is in the pro, the Kuma project.
We all got like a neck.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
No, I missed the sound effect.
I just think they're neat.
I just love my daughters.
Okay.
So be nice to them.
I love them.
Okay.
Let me move over a little bit.
I'm getting smaller and smaller as time goes on.
I don't know how, but anyway.
Okay.
Why do I, why don't I use Scottish slang as much as a regular
Scott?
Okay.
You're actually American born in Canada and then this is an
Eagle.
That was really loud and your Pearson.
I'm going to lower the sound effects.
I'm sorry.
That was really loud.
This is an Eagle holding maple syrup.
I even drew his little legs on to my mom discouraged me from
using slang.
And one, I purposefully speak clear when I streamed you a
multiple factors.
And then this is a Brazilian news anchor and then I put my
face over them.
So yeah, that's that image.
And then this is my mom holding an orange sandal and then
this is my confession about my mom in the orange sandal.
That stupid fucking orange sandal she used to beat me with
and that fucking stung so badly and she'd always go for my
worst honest liquor fucking throw in the microwave the tuna
milk she was for doing that.
Thank God that stupid fucking sandal broke.
I hate sandals now.
God bless America.
When I become president, the sandals market is getting
nuked a fuck man.
I'll be signing that shit front and center when I get old into
the presidency or however the system works.
I don't know.
The tuna melt.
She's a tuna melt for spanking me.
You ready?
Boom.
Oh my God.
Hold on.
This is like a gap.
Oh, no.
There's like, right.
Okay.
No, stop it.
Stop it.
Reflin.
I'm trying to move you darling.
Okay.
There we go.
Right.
Three points for my mom discouraged me zero because
you're a mop head up here and one point.
I actually do try and unseat my words better when I stream.
Basically, my mom still corrects my English when I text and
phone call her today and I denny geese off like the pyramids
the pyramid like the pyramid a geese off because I denny
geese off up.
Get it?
So yeah, my mom used to spank me when I use slang, which
is why I didn't I didn't he send that natural when I use
slang best because that's my mom.
That's my mom.
I'm all ruined it for all of us.
That's right.
Mom, I'm talking about you.
I'm trying to say about you mom.
That's you.
You've ruined my career.
No.
Right.
And then next.
Boom.
We're doing the intermission.
You know why?
Because I got a cup of tea and I knew you feel well.
I was not.
Reflin.
I'm trying to move you darling.
So make sure you're keeping a tally of your score your
entertainment source.
I don't know what I was supposed to do for the entertainment
source.
So allow me.
Allow me for the entertainment source.
Okay, there you go.
Are you entertained?
You having a good time?
Yeah.
Yeah, you having a good time with the entertainment source?
Okay, just checking.
I need to hydrate.
So I'm doing a little.
Yeah.
Feeling thirsty for milk.
Oh, a little reefer.
I should have put my clothes back on.
Okay, there we go.
Thank you.
Okay.
Are you entertained?
Right?
I've got a cup of tea.
I'm going to I'm going to drink some of it.
Okay.
Hmm.
Ah, it's already room temperature.
Lovely.
Hmm.
I have a zero smoke though.
Wait, I've forgotten the number.
No, you're supposed to keep a tally.
I'll go back through.
I'll go back through to make sure.
I need to keep a tally for you.
Are you not entertained?
But yeah.
Oh, wait, hold on a minute.
I have a sound effect for this.
Wait for it.
Oh, no, I missed the sound effect.
Wait, go back.
Go back.
I missed the sound effect.
That's my sound effect because I'm Scottish.
Oh, no, wait.
Okay, it was supposed to be that one.
Okay, right enough.
And then then when the pyramids show up, it's supposed to be this one.
Okay, you ready?
That curse of the Pharaoh shows up.
Hmm.
Literally, that was my sound effect.
Okay.
And then next, this one.
Because we're hydrating.
We need to stay hydrated.
Okay.
We're all hydrated.
We're hydrating.
Wait, that's a Mario 64 thing?
Am I watching rehearsal of Emmy's brain roll stream?
Wait, isn't that bad?
I thought it was funny.
I want to drink your chug jug.
Fortnite battle pass.
Actually, I need a message to the music maker video person.
Who the fuck is Emmy's music video?
I just shit.
Okay, everyone's hydrated.
We're ready to go again.
Okay.
Point your refilling.
I have always wanted to meet a fruit bar.
And oh, and then get it.
It's got a flag and then it says ligma.
It says ligma.
So I've always wanted to meet a fruit bar.
I've always wanted to meet a raccoon because they're so cute and adorable.
Snuffy.
Snuffy, let me meet you.
Or I've always wanted to a giant gorilla.
Any guy just so poor.
But yeah, a giant gorilla.
Just like in those old video games.
Okay.
What animal have I always wanted to meet?
That's right.
Use your brains.
Come on.
Think hard.
Don't worry.
You shouldn't actually do this.
Okay.
Maybe.
I'm going with the raccoon because it's circled.
Boom.
I love gorillas.
Oh, I'm in the way of the gorilla facts.
Hold on.
Let me go in front.
So you get a point for a raccoon.
You get a point for a fruit back because I like the fruit.
Geez.
This this couldn't have gone anywhere.
So if I tried, you get a point for the back because I think bats are cute.
You get a point for the raccoon because I think raccoons are cute.
Why actually really like gorillas?
I've always wanted to feed a gorilla.
Um, I would think it would be nice.
You know how they have programs where you can feed them like through grates and
stuff and like see them interact and that I just think gorillas are really
neat.
Okay.
I just like them.
I think they're cute.
So you get a point for that.
I'd also like to say, I guess when I made this, I'd like to congratulate drugs on
the war on what I also like to congratulate drugs on winning the war on drugs.
Someone said that during my black ops one stream and it just popped into my head
right now.
I guess when I was making it, the deal.
Yeah.
Okay.
We get it.
You were delirious.
That's enough of that.
Okay.
And then actually while I'm here, here's some facts about gorillas.
Where the fuck are the facts?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I just looked up on Google and I don't know what to copy and paste.
I just think they look so nice.
I want to see if I can visit those female ones.
Oh, that's literally what I just said.
Wow.
I'm, I predicted it.
Thingy, my bulber.
I don't know.
I'm getting really, okay.
As I said, I made this like when I was about to go to sleep.
So sorry.
I thought, I thought you were going to get a gorilla fact, but you're getting nothing.
You're getting nothing.
Fun fact.
Gorillas have two inch willies.
What?
Oh my God.
Oh, why is everything so scuffed in the stream?
Okay.
Why was that the one comment I read?
Next.
Mummy wants your ink, your love, your money, your loyalty, your happiness, you.
Oh, this is like a picture of you.
Don't look at this.
I promise it's nothing bad.
And then I just want you to be you.
You are enough.
We flim.
And then I put, oh wait, does this make it really obvious what the answer is?
All of the above?
No, I don't want your worldly possession.
Let's get invested into my, my video game.
How about that?
All right.
And then so yeah, you get, oh no, wait, I didn't do this.
Okay.
I guess three points.
If you pick, I just want you to be you and you get a point for loyalty, love, happiness
and ink money.
You don't get a point for, cause that's not how it works.
It's not how it works.
Um, I don't want your money.
So streamer who built an empire, taking our money.
Ah, exchange of goods and services.
Not our money.
She hates those gifts.
Thank you, D-Man for the extended membership.
So you get a point for it.
Maybe actually, you know what?
You get two points for ink and then you get three points for being you and then one for
loyalty, one for love.
Two for happiness.
Yeah.
I want you to be happy.
I'll put you right on my head and then I think we're already done.
No way.
We're already done.
Hold on.
Oh, wait, let me know.
Let me open up my file.
I'm going to put you on my head.
Okay.
I'm gonna put you on my head for this stream for the rest of the stream.
Hi, wait man.
Can you go on my head please?
Why?
Yes.
Moment.
Yeah.
And you stay right there.
Okay.
Oh, yes.
Look.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I love this.
This is the best technology ever.
Okay.
Now that you're on my head, we will keep you on my head for the rest of the stream.
Please tally your numbers.
Oh, that's really drum rolling.
Hold on.
Wait, I wasn't ready.
I wasn't ready.
Please tally your numbers.
Oh God.
I'm like, I don't know where to put myself.
I'm so tiny.
Okay.
So I'm going to have to point with my head.
So technically the maximum score is seven out of three.
But the game in one messed up a little bit.
So if you want to do the triple gaming thing.
Okay.
So if you're at number seven, you're in the red zone.
Your correction training is needed right now.
Bend over.
Okay.
If you're in 14, you're not quite where I need you, but that's okay.
It's an excuse to spend more time together and then I've got grooms you harder.
I groom, groom, groom, groom, groom.
And then 24.
Now that you're clearly mind broken, I get to do whatever pops into my head.
Huh?
And then look, it's you up.
And that's my face when I'm coming at you with my wee fangs.
And then that's it.
That's all prepared because I was totally raised to do anymore.
That's literally it.
I kid you not.
I, I have not had a good enough rest.
Yes.
Yeah, I don't even have a clap sound effect.
I can just play crowd disappointed because there wasn't too much.
Nope.
Oh, no, I've just crowd disappointed.
Isn't there?
Okay.
All my other sound effects are now broken for the new ones.
I don't know how I've did that.
I've broken all my old sound effects, but my new ones are working fine.
Tee-hee.
Wait.
There are three times seven is 21.
Oh, it is.
How did I mess that up so badly?
I haven't.
Well.
Anyway.
What were your scores?
I was 21.
I don't know where the extra points came from.
I don't know.
What were you 19, 16, 11, 12?
Now remember, it's for fun.
There was a lot of questions.
You three, three as negative two.
That's not even possible.
Shocking.
There's a lot more grooming needed around these parts.
Clearly.
What's going on here?
You need correction immediately.
My internet was out zero real 15.
I just barely qualified for mind broken.
Without bonus points 18 with bonus 21, 62% passing grade 20.
I didn't know the last question had a bottomless opinion.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, it's an option.
I have no idea how to count the last slide because it went all of the above.
I don't know either.
As long as you had fun.
That's the main thing.
Um.
Testing on clear.
It seems I've become a crustacean.
A busty crustacean.
I'd say, but I'm pretty sure that's broken as well.
Yeah, but I'm screwed.
Can I model still?
Okay.
Right.
We just don't love me if I had pinpoint eyes.
My eyes are so tiny.
Oh my God.
I love this.
Oh, you know when someone takes their glasses off and their eyes are tiny?
Thank you, Nogen for becoming a member.
Thank you, Anonymous.
Our money isn't good enough.
Cry Anonymous.
Not like that.
Crack head eyes.
No.
I supposed to be like shock.
Oh my God.
I look like when someone takes their glicks off.
This looks awful.
Why is that amusing me?
Oh my God.
I can have beady lips.
I can have beady little hypnosis eyes.
They're so tiny.
Imagine a hypnosis, a hypnotist being like looking to my eyes and her eyes are like fucking tiny.
Looking to my eyes and you're like, where?
I can't see them, bitch.
Looking to my eyes.
I want your car.
Oh my God.
Me discovering I have a moose after three months of streaming.
Why did you not let me break you in?
Hmm.
Anonymous, is it odd I got about half of the more personal questions on food and behavior, right?
Because my neuro-spacy spider senses gated my hand.
Clearly squids of a tentacle ink together.
Have a good one, Frank.
Thank you.
Oh, so I'm crying.
Thank you for getting the chicken question, right?
I love chicken.
Would you still love me if I was?
Yeah.
And we just don't give me it anyway.
Oh my God.
Wait, would you still give me your thingy if I had pinpoint eyes?
P.V.
Mummy, I just received my test results.
I can't.
It says I'm 10.
Oh, I'm 10.
102% refling with 2% margin error.
Yeah.
You could.
That's killing.
When I said, what's this?
Oh, why are you confused about refling?
Huh, darling?
What are you confused about?
Are you confused about what happens next after stream to you?
Don't need to be confused.
You're still confused.
Why are you confused, baby?
What is this one?
Oh, it's a sweat.
I want to make you sweat.
I don't have anything else.
Anyways, that's me.
And that sound was not a chair.
Did my chair fart?
I'm not getting blamed for farting if it was my chore.
Right.
Let's get this post in the frame.
In no particular way.
That's so tame.
And he's that source.
He can't receive the mummy brainwaves with the tin foil.
No wonder he's confused.
My puppy.
Are we going to become calamari?
I don't eat you.
Not unless you want that one role play that I was going to do.
Hey, you know that one role play?
Yeah, I was going to do that.
I got max points.
Should we make out real and true?
I'm going to read some marshmallow.
I didn't.
I didn't really have fast.
I was going to blast through that to be honest.
I was like, there's supposed to be a bit more content for today's stream.
Which is a whipsie.
My dad.
And today's stream.
Mummy for you.
Would you like to?
Can I put hold on?
Are you ready to go for a swim?
This is so cute.
Okay.
I'm not going to put you.
I'll put you on my shoulder.
How about that?
Oh, now you look like a hair clip.
No, you're not here.
No, don't stop.
Stop zooming in on my googly-boogly.
Okay.
I'll put you on my shoulder.
No, not my hair.
The shoulder.
Yeah.
You stay on my shoulder, baby.
Monk.
Okay, then.
Watched the John McGlatchelong last night.
Thank you for giving me an excuse to rewatch them.
Bruh, I was crying my eyes out like crazy in it.
Thank you, crazy Jessie for the super chat.
Reefling earrings?
I don't know if I could fit you on my ears because I can hardly see them.
But like now I got two reeflings.
I think I have a third one.
It's just you looking all shy.
There you go.
Yes, I have a folder of reeflings.
No, I will not apologize for it.
I think it's cute.
Look at my little reeflings.
They're all white, white.
Ta-da!
Reefling babies everywhere.
I'm gonna rest inside your hair, Tufts.
They would be quite thingy.
Shoulders give us a good view like that and you'll look so cute on me.
Do you have the inkling?
I post the inkling a lot.
I may be able to grab it from chat.
How come mum lets you have two reeflings?
Wait, let me see if I can grab the reefling ink one.
Ah, I'm gonna have to go on YouTube together.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Is that the strong e-cut?
Oh, streaming lot.
Um, actually yes.
Yes?
Question mark.
I actually am streaming live and I'm mucking about with a reefling.
But it doesn't get inkling.
Any inkling?
Is it gonna be tiny?
My question is this gonna be tiny?
Am I about to do SNH by accident?
Where did that save to?
I'm wondering why your mum didn't want you speaking Scottish slang.
What's bad about it?
My mum just wanted me to speak proper English.
Like, not use slang.
Like, she hates when I say like, oh, I did good in that.
She always says, no, you did well.
And I'm like, mum, oh my god, we're actually Scottish.
Um, I do not know why she had such a stick-off or arse about it, honestly.
Um, where did that image save?
On to the desktop, right?
So cast the fucking file over then.
Where's my reefling?
My wee inkling.
Where are you?
Where did you go?
Oh, there you are.
You're tiny though.
Oh no, can I make you bigger?
Oh, you're so pixelated.
Oh no, where did I put you?
Well, I put you in my hair like an accessory.
Oh, you're so tiny and pixelated.
Well, I'll do some SNH for you.
My pixels.
Right, I'll put you over there.
Yeah, we've got the whole gang together.
My little pixels.
Not like this.
I don't know why it came so tiny.
My wee inkling.
Yeah, but yes, thank you Grimby Vela for the super chat.
Yeah, my mom just didn't want me speaking slang.
Um, she just didn't like it.
And I don't know why, because her parents...
Actually, no, you know what?
I know what I think about it.
My grandparents didn't really speak much slang.
Now that I think about it, hmm...
So I think she just tried to instill it in me.
You all got any more than pixels.
Like, he's trying his best.
Be nice to him.
He's a good boy.
He's a very good boy.
Alright, let me refresh Marshimallow.
What?
Mommy, I knew I was going, but I didn't realize how far.
I get hard during your streams.
You what?
How?
I'm not doing anything.
I'm just adding...
What?
Is it not normal?
Wait a minute.
Oh yeah, I put together like the most shit postie stream
and you're like...
Yeah, you like that?
Is that what you want?
He's already been conditioned.
The accent and the voice.
Okay, okay, I'll give you that.
I like that.
Hello, Strony.
Hello, Ruflin.
Wompam.
Calamari.
Thank you for being you.
Yapadkwa.
Also, I find it cute the way you've been saying baby.
I love you.
What's the matter, baby?
Would you rather eat a baby goat or a matter baby?
And then you go, matter baby.
What's the matter, baby?
I go, I don't know.
What's the matter with you?
Calcar, thank you for the extended membership.
That Ruflin definitely scored a 24 somehow.
It's your fault.
That Ruflin's in the deep.
He's rolling in the deep.
My heart and soul.
After the watching your ASMR,
my brain too has been rewired to your voice.
Strony's mind cannot comprehend that some Ruflin's come hard.
Just based off of the emotional connection.
Oh, that's so cute though.
What the fuck?
Me?
I bet you, you know what?
Emotional connection will be severed after overwatch too.
I'm going to start ordering you around those maps,
even though I've not even played the new ones or anything.
I'll be like, ah, Denny Ken, what are you friends on?
Fucking go to Anna and Nanome right now.
You're literally the bond will be severed during overwatch.
I can already tell now.
Momay, I got 17 out of 21.
Does that mean I'm in the yellow or the green?
Because if I'm in the green,
I promise to watch even more of your VODs.
Stream sub, if I'm fully yours.
Baby, you don't have to do that.
You are doing well enough.
What's going on here?
Oh, I've seen that one.
Whatever happened to the audio of you and me being sisters,
I never got finished.
I never finished the one-on-one scripts that I was going to make with the girls.
Mummy does only reeflings, so don't push the payload.
I think maybe at the end of my 100 VTuber ASMR collab challenge,
I think it would be nice if the last five were the girls,
so it would be near the end of the year.
I'm going to try and finish my little thing by the end of the year.
I think that would be quite nice.
I think I became addicted after the pregnancy ASMR audio.
I think we're doing bath time where I get you all nice and clean,
ready for bed, which I think is really cute.
Get to that point, you're my best.
You love being a tank, yes, I'll be your personal mercy.
Oh yes, my little little reefling.
But yes, I think it would be very nice and poetic.
Poetic? No, that's not the word.
I would just be nice if the end of my little goal was my gen mates, one-on-one,
and then that would be my 100 VTuber collabs,
because I'm about to get back on it like a car bonnet, yes.
Hi, Stronny, hi, reefling.
The Forget Your Name ASMR really affected me, and I wasn't expecting it.
I haven't really experienced hypnosis, and I don't know what it's supposed to feel like,
but for a while after the stream, there was a mental block
that stopped me from thinking of my name as anything other than reefling.
I am your Stronny and body-mind and soul-loving Stronny.
I'm nervous about the next hypnosis stream.
I'm not going to do ASMR for the next hypnosis stream.
I'm just going to talk into the SMB with the echo effect,
and I'm nervous about it, but I'm going to get a clicker as well and see how it goes.
I need to do my research for the next hypnosis stream.
Don't expect it to go super quickly, okay?
Get on the fucking payload, you stupid monkey, you big fat dick.
Literally, look, I get raging if we can win and we're not winning,
but yee, I already have a clicker.
I want to get one, and then the next hypnosis live stream is going to be through the SMB.
It's not going to be through the 3DO.
Apparently my reverb was really too harsh as well.
Well, I don't remember changing the sentence though,
so I don't know if it kind of did a reset because it's plugins that I use for that kind of thing.
Say, Stroners, what was your peak over what shrank?
The one above Platinum?
I've forgotten the name.
Diamond?
Diamond.
My brain felt really numb and it felt good after yesterday's hypnosis stream.
Ah, you like that?
I always get so worried. Diamond?
Yeah, diamond.
I really like the hypnosis, but could you dial back a little bit on the echo effect?
Yeah, I got that in my marshmallow and I was like, oopsies.
I don't know if maybe the plugin reset and it was a bit too harsh.
Maybe a bit too harsh?
I don't know.
And the same peak rank.
Mummy, you're going to have to carry us.
Why are you guys gold?
Be honest.
I started out silver and I made it to Diamond, so I'm proud of myself,
but I've not played Overwatch 2 so silver.
Oh my God, Kolker, thank you for the extended membership.
Did I even say thank you?
Thank you, Kolker, everybody.
That refling was scored at 24.
I think I said the message now.
The echo effect made it better?
I'm wondering if the echo effect on SMB only would be good.
As I said, any live stream of the scripts will be made into videos,
so like, I won't fuck it up as much.
How did she guess I would hard stock gold?
Just call Moira, suck the fucking soul out of them.
Fetch me their souls!
Basically it's what you need to do.
Just play Moira and go for it.
Oh wait, I actually have...
No, I don't know where the balances are anymore,
so don't listen to me, okay?
Hypnosis doesn't really work on me from the little I tried,
but the hypnosis was still relaxing.
It's nothing more.
Hi, Strony, I got fill points.
Does that mean you owe me?
You owe me now, if so, I'm happy with this.
I'm going to walk you like a dog.
I see what's going on.
I think I'm trying, baby.
Why?
Are my chiefsters streaming?
I'm going to be directing to our Suntium.
Don't be a very...
What did I have planned?
I had something else planned.
What did I have planned today?
Now hold on a minute, what did I have planned?
Oh, a movie, watch along.
Those are my favorites.
I'm going to wade the rabbit later.
I'm going to read some more Mushy Mallows
and then we're going to wade the rabbit.
I do apologize for how tiny the stream was.
I'm literally SPH shaming the stream.
I did not expect it to be so short, genuinely.
I was very delirious putting this together,
but I like blasted through it.
It was a very...
How about we just agree to call it an experimental stream?
Sorry, my brain was literally mashing together
all of those vowels at once.
How about we agree to call it an experimental stream
that when Ori, it went Ori,
which is probably when we go back to it,
but it was Ori.
The next education stream is going to be about drugs.
I'm going to teach you about drugs.
Like cocaine now.
Heroin.
Drugs.
And I'm qualified to talk about it
and you want to know why?
Because Scotland is the overdose capital of Europe.
Round of applause.
Hold on, hold on.
Let me get it up, let me get it up.
Round of applause Scotland for
overdose city.
When will we see...
Oh, congrats, congrats Scotland.
Oh, overdose city.
It's not a good thing.
No, it's not, but at least I can say it.
I would say Hypnosis doesn't work on me,
but it's thinking about you for the rest of the day.
I'll let you consult Ori.
I want to do...
My next one isn't as pleasant.
Well, it's a lot more diabolical,
my next hypnosis stream.
It may or may not be pet play
in turning you into a puppy.
I'm sorry.
If only I wanted to do it.
I'm going to get a clicker and I'm going to get a color
and a leash and a dog bowl.
And it's going to be fucked up.
But I'm doing it.
And nothing can stop me.
This stream corresponds with your hate,
so it fits.
You call me under that shirt?
I'm 100...
What am I in American units?
Because you're all American.
In American units?
Oh my God, is that even a sentence?
I taped in 162 centimeters in American units
and I'm apparently 1.7 yard.
And what do you use?
Feet? You use feet.
I'm 5 foot 3.
I'm just over 5 foot 3.
I'm literally 5 foot 3.1.
Feet?
162 centimeters.
No, 162.
Short?
How tall are you then?
You fan dance.
How tall are you? 5'11?
5'3 short now?
I don't know.
162 short?
The point zero is really important.
That fuck is 162!
What are they feeding you in your country?
Jesus!
Go back down.
5'10? 5'11? 5'7?
175? 5'11?
6'3!
Fuckin' sit down, man.
Save some height for the rest of us.
What the fuck?
Bloody clunge magnet over here identified.
I'm so sorry if you don't know what that means.
To the two British people that are laughing their heads off at that time.
Love you.
What the fuck?
Why are you all so tall?
What did you eat?
I used to eat my carrots as a child.
That was funny.
What the fuck is a clunge?
Guys, I fucked up.
Wraith blend.
I made a oopsie-oopsie.
I need to come in really close to tell you the secret, okay?
I took the picture of me with the soup.
But I got cold feet, okay?
But the reason I got cold feet is...
I did blur everything.
But you know how I have...
I have small assets.
I have small personalities.
If you didn't know,
when you have small personalities,
your nip-noops don't point straight forward.
I have feeding nip-noops,
and I got really embarrassed,
and I don't know if I have the strength to put the picture online.
I'm scared.
I don't know, people will make fun of my nip-noops.
I got the milk drinking cane,
which means that they aren't pointing straight at you like eyeballs.
So I don't know if I have the balls to post that right now.
I'll keep looking at it, but...
I'm not sure.
We so only swear we won't make fun of the nip-noops.
Um...
I demand soup and milk right now.
Don't care, still inking.
Cross-eyed? No, they don't go inwards.
If you have booby feeding...
So in order to feed the child, it should technically go...
like, slightly upwards like this.
Free the titty as much as I can fit.
Cross-eyed boobies? No, they're no cockeyed tits.
I don't got cockeyed tits, the other way, the other way.
But like, because of the way I was holding the plate,
I pushed them, like, I had a bowl of my soup.
I like, pushed them together, and they look funny.
You're pregnant? No!
No, I'm not getting... No!
Only Magento.
I'm not getting pregnant, mom.
Didn't you not know what happens to your color of your pasties
if you get pregnant?
Inverted!
I just cropped them out, put googly eyes on them.
That'd be interesting.
Anonymous, thank you for the tip.
I've heard it says that Edinburgh is the culture capital of Scotland
because of the great culture of friendly people.
In classical Alharka texture,
all of which are great to see when not buying heroin!
I'm looking forward to the just say no stream.
No stream? Yeah, you want the drug screen?
No, I'm getting a drug screen.
Put whipped cream on them?
You're nursing? Yeah, the reeflings.
That's about it.
We love you in every shape and form.
Yeah, even if my boobies don't point straight far away,
because I got Westies and boobies.
Yeah, there's different types of boobies in the world.
I got the kind that I fall for.
Good, good moment for sure.
I'll take a look at it again, okay?
And then I might get the balls to post it.
But don't be surprised if I never post another thing like that again.
And...
Oh boobah, boobah, boobah.
You don't have to read this on stream or anything.
But what if I do? What happens if I do?
I've been on the road again?
Oh, no, you're...
I've been on the road to recovering from alcoholism.
And I'm six months sober!
Let's go!
Render for pause reeflings!
Six months sober, I.A.
Let's go! That's amazing!
It's been a lot of trial and error with therapy and medicine
to get my brain in a good place.
Exactly!
When I found out about you and other girls, it was perfect timing
because I was struggling.
Getting to listen to interact with you has been a lot of fun.
I feel like I get to hang out on stream almost every day.
Thank you for everything you do for us reeflings and girdleys.
You truly are wonderful person.
Let's go reeflings!
Six months sobriety is so big.
Did you know you no longer have any of the physiological addictions
in your body now?
It's all just in your head.
And I know you can defeat the demons.
You know that.
Keep bad.
It's not easy, but as I said, your body no longer needs it.
So it's all psychological next and if you're getting the help you need,
you defeated the demons.
Isn't that about how long you've been streaming?
Six months?
Fucking hell!
I've not even reached the three month mark yet!
It's not even been the three months yet.
It will be three months on the first of September.
A coincidence?
I think not.
Eh.
Hee hee hee.
I repeat myself, but don't post if you're not comfortable.
I'll take a look at it again and see what I think.
I just, I edit a bit and I was like...
You know, I was kind of just like...
I'm not sure because I don't really do that.
And...
Me.
I thought it was four months.
No, we started June, so...
June 1st, July 1st, August...
Wait, am I an idiot?
Yeah, by the end of August will be three full months of streaming.
So the fourth month will start in September,
but that's not four months of streaming.
That's how maths works, right?
Surely that's how maths works.
Yes.
So I'm about to hit my three months.
First of December is the start of the f-
I'm gonna burp.
Eh.
I'm gonna burp, burp, burp, burp.
No, no, no, no.
Do not worry, there will still be the refund on your hair pixelated.
He's only stuck by the ink, honestly.
I need to pee, actually.
Refling, can you help me?
I need to pee.
Stop, I'm gonna turn you into the...
I'm gonna make you accidentally enjoy that kink.
Stop!
I was joking.
No, I'm joking.
I'm joking, because I'm gonna accidentally give you the...
E.
I'll whip some of it immediately so I can play with your small test.
Stop.
Grip them so much, I'll have to get my hands surgically removed.
Oh my god.
Eh.
On stream right now, you have a minor popping noise in the left ear coming through.
It's really faint and intermittent.
At least, Kate, wait, right now?
Eh, pop now?
Better not be fucking popping.
Do you know how much I paid for you, SMB7?
A whole hundred and something dollars.
Better not be a pop noise.
I was on the 3D.
Oh my gosh, my stream being popping now?
Is it still popping?
I can't hear it.
The first exposure to existence was Hold It While You Pee.
Well, I hope you're ready for the...
The sequel.
Let me stack donuts on it.
Please, let me stack donuts on it.
What's the point?
Please.
I'll even fluff you.
Please, let me stack donuts on it.
I went to Krispy Kreme.
Look, I got ice...
Ice...
Is it icing?
I don't eat donuts.
Is it icing flavored donuts where it's got like the thingy?
Please.
It's cracked again.
Shut the fuck up.
See, I fucking bam.
Let's start smacking this shit with this mic.
I don't know.
Is it because I'm peeking at myself?
Oh!
Did it peek when I did that? Be honest.
Did it peek when I sung...
Maybe five donuts?
Speaking of a glee donut?
No, it seems random.
Is my cable dying?
Do you get fucking done
if you crack something like your crackly bastard, you?
You're the fuckest crackling.
Is it you?
It's my headset.
It's my headset that was crackling back at you.
I think.
I think it's my headset.
You don't hear it anymore, do you?
I think it's my head.
Not the headset.
Call me a baker,
because I'm going to glaze that hole.
Yeah, it was my headset
looking back into you.
Sorry.
I have voice jammer on.
I'm sorry.
I think it's my head.
Turn me into a twinkie.
No!
Here are my results.
Your results of what?
When you send a cat box link
and it's like really...
There's no other...
Oh, your results are the fucking thing.
That's so good.
Someone...
Oh, he goes,
ooh, ah, ah, the gorilla?
No, no.
He just stayed behind for correction.
Real and true, though.
Hey, Johnny.
How are we doing?
Before I found Villalour,
I was struggling with grief and loss
of someone special to me.
I'm sorry to hear about that.
About a special as a Oshie is to a fan.
I was in a dark space in my life
and struggling
ever since I found more laughs
than I could have expected
and more rest will sleep
than much before.
Please tell Emy, Icy,
Azura, Shibi, and Mercy
that they have no idea
about the life they saved
in their debuts.
Aww, that's so precious.
Thank you, little whistling.
I don't think it would matter
how your body looks
if that's how you look,
then that's how you look.
No shame about it
if you stay true to yourself.
I'm just gonna artificially
photoshop my nips.
I mean, it's blurred.
Typical nation.
Thank you for your super chat
and your sharing.
And you'll have someone
especially a little trust.
No, I'm not allowed
to photoshop my nips.
It's not like they're too big
or anything.
It's just got,
I just got booby feeding nips
and it's like, why?
I don't plan.
The only thing that's
allowed to hang off my boob
is a wifelin, okay?
I shit with a shit.
On your wifelin.
I love to do that.
You didn't have to cut me off.
Give us to him straight.
Right, I'll analize the picture
a bit more after the stream.
How about that?
Also, both my Patreon audios
are gonna be uploaded today.
They're all ready.
One of them is so keep this rule play.
I can't remember
if I did a source boy.
Hold on.
Access denied.
Uh...
Ah, the fricking
closed the file off.
They need to body share it.
That was me.
That was my PC if you heard that.
Although I've muted the desktops,
I don't think you heard that at all.
You didn't have to cut me off.
Speaking about Patreon now,
keep returning to the recent
Kiss and One.
I don't think it's allowed.
I think it has to be wrote it together.
I'm ready to write the one for October.
No, September next.
Because there's a missing one in September.
September.
And then we get to write it again.
I think I'm in too deep.
I'm on vacation.
Happy vacation!
Are you in the sunny place?
I know I can think about
the streams I'm gonna miss.
I'm gonna try and have fun,
but it's really hard.
Have I been grimmed?
Slightly.
I have fun on vacation though.
The vacation!
Vacation.
On holiday.
We go.
Yes, yes.
Like, sorry, that was my...
I did not fart!
I did not fart
if that came up in the microphone, okay?
I did not fart.
Leave me alone.
I didn't fart.
If you're on holiday,
you should enjoy it.
Like, my content's always gonna be there.
And I know the VODs
aren't exactly the same.
But there isn't that exciting stuff this week.
I would say this week,
like, in terms...
Oh, hold on.
Something's moving.
Who?
Oh, the background.
Something was moving.
Where's me?
I would say, maybe...
They kill it with fire, with djinn.
I'm flew, yo.
It's gonna be...
She must get that all the time.
I'm so sorry.
I'm gonna have to apologize to her
in the voice chat.
That'll be interesting
because I'm not playing kill it with fire, too.
We're gonna play...
Mummy, are we supposed to have
the background music on?
Do you want it on?
Or do you just want me?
I don't have my background music set up.
Hold on.
You're getting YouTube instead.
You're getting YouTube music instead.
Copyright free.
Legend of Zelda Lo-Fi.
Strony, why do you always put that on?
I don't know.
It's just really nice and relaxing, okay?
Oh, sorry.
It sped up.
Sorry, it was sped up.
Hold on.
Let's slow down there with a harp.
Oh, wait.
No, my headset is broken.
I can't let you listen to desktop audio.
Oh, shit.
Right, hold on a minute.
Hold on.
Wait, I just realized the schedule's on my face.
Hold on a minute.
Okay, I'm gonna go to my loading screen
in order to grab my background music, okay?
Don't panic.
I said don't panic.
I'm still here.
I just need to grab my background theme from here, okay?
Stop panicking.
I'm still here.
Okay, there we go.
Boom.
Just like that.
I never left.
I'm just like that.
Paste.
Rename.
No, paste.
Paste.
Right.
Oh, my God.
Did you hear it?
No, I didn't know.
I'm in here.
Did you hear it?
You can still hear it.
What, the popping?
The body, oh, no.
I did not hit replaying.
I did not.
Oh, hi, replay.
Oh, she back.
No, the popping is gone.
No, that's fine.
Okay, it better be.
The only thing that should be remaining is
the hit popping, cooking stream.
That was terrible.
That's fine.
I can hear faint music.
Is it too faint?
Get that bad boy up.
Oh, my secret project might have an update.
Hold on.
Okay.
My secret project has an update.
Honestly, I can't tell you about it.
You're going to be a good little weakling.
You're going to wait and you're going to have so much
patience.
We're the fun we're going to have together.
And then when I can finally leak it, it's
fucking over for you.
Going to leak on your face, down your chest,
your snail trail, right on top of your tentacle.
But not yet.
No secret leaking yet.
No secret leaking time.
I'll be patient.
Yeah, you can wait.
I'll leak all of them in.
Wait, but very excited.
We love the full package.
You silly woman.
We don't pick and choose what bits you have.
This isn't build a bear.
Do you think I can get a build a bear of icicle?
When I say I love you, I mean, I love you.
I wouldn't have gone through that if I didn't love you.
If you think your nip nips are going to stop us from loving you.
Okay, I don't like the full.
I don't like the full.
I won't be.
Because I'm completely blurred.
You can't see anything.
And literally the meme is like, here's my chicken soup.
And the worst part about the chicken soup is it
fricking congealed.
So it doesn't look like soup in the picture.
It looks like medieval slop, which makes the picture
10 times worse.
Everyone's not even going to care about the background.
Everyone's going to be like, what is that medieval slop
in your bowl?
And it's cause my soup congealed.
I should have taken the picture the day before,
but I'm going to say something even worse because it congealed.
I could like tilt the plate towards the camera.
Like add it in a bowl and I tilted it.
I could like tilt it towards the camera and I took
like a couple of different photos.
So I had to add water.
So like I take the photos and then I added water and
microwaved it and it got a bit more soupy.
That means more collagen.
That's a good sign of a good stock.
I did do chicken bones.
The chicken fat solidified.
How did you make your soup to where it's solidified?
It just got hard.
Not hard, but it just became one solid mass.
Really.
So chicken grill, honestly.
Yeah.
A little bit.
I mean, it was delicious though.
I was so surprised.
I like not to get back on soup talk.
I'm already getting back on soup talk.
I roasted all the vegetables first and all I did was
extra wizard olive oil and paprika.
And I roasted it in the oven for 30 minutes.
And then I added it and then I drained the chicken
bones out and like kept the stock and then
I added the lentils to boil.
The lentils was really good.
And I found a soup.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
This sounds so boring.
I found a soup broth mix, which I'm really excited to use.
So I'm going to use up all my red lentils first.
And then I'm going to buy this soup broth mix,
which looks so good, by the way.
It has like all these delicious little lentils.
It's like green split pea and red and like barley as well,
which is good for you.
And I think it's called black-eyed pea lentils or something
like that.
And they're really delicious.
They're almost like slimy texture when they're cooked.
I just think it's really nice.
I think they're yummy.
And it helps me get like more vegetables in as well
because I always eat vegetables.
I drink fruit juices, like actual 100% mashed up fruit juices.
But I want to try mummy's cooking.
I have terrible news.
I never write down the recipe.
I just wing it.
I'm like channeling my medieval peasant history
and my family's lineage and just being like,
eh, that'll do.
Into the broth it goes.
That'll be fine.
A bit of salt and I'll call it a day.
Black-eyed feed, doesn't that sound like?
No, like that's an actual lentil.
They've got like little black dots on them
and they're called like black-eyed lentils.
Whoopsies.
If you come to a con, could you please bring us some food?
I bring shortbread, why not?
Stew, crusty.
Ah, I forgot fucking baguettes again!
Shit!
I forgot to get crusty bread for my chomp.
Why am I born like this?
And no, I'm not going back to the shops.
I don't want to go outside.
I'm actually right.
So here's the tea.
So I've been getting food delivered to my house.
Either takeaway or like actual food to make stuff with.
But I'm scared to go outside because I don't want to get sick
because I want to be able to stream
and I'm worried about getting sick
every time I go outside.
Like I come in and wash my hands like I'm mini.
I come like, James, James!
Get off me because I don't want to get sick
and like I wash my face as well.
And sometimes if I feel really bad
I get a shower when I get back.
So I'm getting really, really scared, okay?
I don't want to get sick.
I want to be with my refunds, okay?
Even if I'm sick, you already know damn well
I'm going to be streaming.
I don't care if it's a short stream.
I'll be streaming.
I'll be like, great.
And today, like I'll have a snuffing nose
and today we're going to learn about viruses.
Who's ready to learn about the snake oil
that is virus medicine?
Basically.
If I get sick, but I'm not going to get sick.
And like COVID misses out.
Gay or race?
Yeah.
Well, I don't think you could handle a con.
No, I'm going to...
I don't know either.
I'm going to have to be severely medicated
if I go to a second visit.
What do you mean you're scared of going in the outside world?
Yeah, sometimes.
Snake oil sales.
If you get bad sleep, you will get sick.
Can you...
You can't get virus from sleeping though.
Just a little anesthesia.
Well, the medicine I take to go outside for that
does put your brain to sleep.
It's the Azepam in particular.
And it's hard to remember everything.
Or for me as in...
The sun is a deadly laser.
Doesn't sound fun if you're completely out of your mind
jogged up at a convention.
Just don't go.
Five head true real.
No sleep awakens your immune system?
Lack of sleep weakens.
Oh, weakens!
Not weakens.
It weakens your immune system?
Hold on.
Lack of sleep immune system.
Hacker man, I'm in.
We're about to get...
Yes, lack of sleep can affect your immune system.
Studies show that people who don't get quality sleep
are enough or lightly to get sick after being exposed to a virus
such as the common cold.
Merda putana!
Shit!
That mean I can't go outside anymore?
Not without rest, shit.
I was kinda enjoying getting all my veggies and stuff.
Cause I can't order the veggies.
Order.
No, I never finished it.
So I never said it.
I can't...
Can't what?
I can't get fresh vegetables delivered.
Cause they always put the freaking thing that's about to expire the next day
when you get like the home delivery thing.
So, yeah.
Just live like us and become a neat.
I mean, I'm technically already there.
Lack of sleep affects so much.
Immune function can give you spots.
That's really random.
Gain weight and pair cognitive function.
Probably cognitive function.
I have to admit, if you...
Those slides were wild.
Like, I'm not even being funny.
What the fuck...
Is in it wildly inappropriate?
Probably is.
What the fuck is the fruit bat slide?
Literally, what the fuck is that?
A fruit bat.
And instead of putting like a piece of fruit, like a strawberry,
I said it was like a bit more like...
Yeah.
Talk about being cognitively impaired.
Like, what even is this?
Intermission, hydration check.
And then I literally have what sound effect?
Like...
Oh wait, you can't even hear that.
Oh no, wait, you didn't hear that sound effect?
I don't know.
Oh, maybe you did.
Like, what?
So yeah, like my bat.
Literally a fruit bat.
Like, bro, how wildly inappropriate is that?
It's like, ehhh, ehhh, ehhh, ehhh, ehhh, ehhh.
Shut the fuck up, that's not how it works.
You already know how that's not how it works.
Oh, we all know that's not how it works.
It's not how it works.
Ligma is a fruit though.
What?
No, it's not a fruit.
It's ligma or fruit.
Am I being pranked?
It's...
you pranked me what the fuck bro I believed you I was like oh that has
validity because I don't know the name of a lot of exotic fruits you freaking
pranked me fuck Zach spy on thank you for the extended membership let's go
two months okay let's what happens at two months of Craig Nancy who's Nancy I'm
strong bones start to replace the cartilage the embryo begins to move
although the mother cannot feel it yet by the end of the second month your baby
no your feet is your is I got your embryo is about 2.54 centimeters and Greg
and Nancy make all our babies pregnant fell for a 10-year-old joke let's go I
know like Matt is the meme I actually thought it was a fruit though you the
way you said it so confidently fake it until you make it and it worked validity
you just got pranked nah you should do a sequel to the pregnancy stream after
nine months is that when I dropped the baby one I'm putting you I give you a
little baby bath and I tell you that you're so adorable and you came out so
cute because some babies come out with a really smushed face but you didn't
because you're so perfect and perfect and perfect yeah wait is that mean 10
years old how old is it okay let me tell you how old is the legma me legma is
one of my favorite fruits are along with up dog no you're done calcare get put in
the bin hold on how do I reply I need to open up stream hold on hold on let me
open up stream so I can reply to the super chat nope I'm not having that I'm
not having that I'm not having it that's me I'm not having it reply oh you're
done you can't your words cannot hurt me anymore calcare
yeah putting you in the bin you're a naughty boy get put in the bin I've lost
so much ink during this last month thanks Johnny basically was thank you for
the extent of membership why not lose some more right now I encourage it
you've been in the bed you're in the naughty corner instead if you guys start
acting up I'll put you in the naughty corner
mmm put you in the new corner post suit picking I'll maybe reconsider oh
a rifle in right if I I don't wanna I don't know I don't know I don't know I
can't remember I must I must I must deliberate if I post this week
separation from mummy's ultimate torture as soon as I hit in broadcast it's
over for the both of us we're just like an absolute tires actually I'm gonna go
can someone confirm is she be gonna keep streaming because I just realized I
yapped and I said I was gonna redirect into her and I just realized that I know
can someone new she be streaming ask her if she's streaming more mummies asking
if she can redirect into her mummy mummy yapped a little too long hey nice boys
hey nice super chat do you like the accent I bet you do I bet you do dank
Lord we smash and you like the way I see your what your name in my voice and my
accent the Mario accent Australia your voice is so fake I this is why my voice
is what I sound like I'm mumbling and you can't even understand me that's fine
no that's my problem don't you don't you have a member streaming 20 yet I'm still
getting redirected into her problem now I don't know maybe she'll extend the stream
just a wee bit I've no go cool well it's not up to me I snow up to me I'm just here
farting and shitting oh no I'm not well I might maybe later I just realized I need
to do the peeler allegations as well nice cock the booty Lord thank you for the
fact no you don't your accent skills and Irish you leave the pillar no do you
not remember the deal if Azura does the peeler allegations I have to finish it
off it's over the peelerers one the peelerers one it's over she reached the
milestone to do the peeler allegation she literally got paid like seven
thousand us dollars to pee in the microphone
she won you won I don't know what to say you win peelerers you win well may can
you finish off to a fun fact cut a fish at three hearts how do we capture one of
yours you already have my heart thank you everything for the reflins pee in the
mic no no with that nearby the Peelings no you're gonna become the Peelings so
she has to do it first and then I'll do mine I don't know if we should Emmy it
and I'll do a short two hour stream but I'll drink as much as possible we Emmy
need this bitch already have a V8 turbo haunt me at Broly legend with the Emmy
profile picture yeah you would say peeler allegations for the win you are
probably there teasing the crap out of her when she was doing it don't pee on
expensive electronic on the denial strip when are we getting positive
affirmations ASMR do you want video or do you want live stream video or live
stream you can have it either way you can have both if you want honestly I
could do I could write the script and then perform it live and then do the
video as well you'll be be old actually hi bleeding heart video sounds good but
yeah how about that I do need to kind of get a bit of a fire lit under me arse when
it comes to recording more audios unfortunately both at different points
meant to do no thanks you well you didn't have to thank you for the legend 99
to be specific underscore to be even more specific of course you can go
extraordinary just means your immune systems less effective you still have
white blood cells it doesn't make you immune compromised better not the booty
Lord I seem to remember a youtuber who covered the studio with plastic wrap
and then she got an idea an idea for coming
dark lord weed smash please stay longer lapping fighting games with you in the
background yeah you beat that boss you mashed those buns XY XY BB a then be
roll backwards yeah come up beat them up that's how it works right are you
playing the monkey game there's a monkey game that came up I'm strong I love
telling you how much I love you you're such a silly sausage hey wait I say
silly sausage and I enjoy hanging out in streams I'm seriously so thankful you
stream all the time and I love so much ASMR stuff this and as I'll be living on
my own it's scary to deal with last time I was living by myself someone tried to
kick my front door and put a born-in dog sign out front there was like a pull
done by thieves and if you have a beware of dog sign a lot of them get deterred
and it's better to deter a percentage of them than all of them even if you don't
have a yapper wouldn't that just sound like pouring water in your mic if you
did that uh no because the stream isn't consistent I would have to like squat
over the thing and wait how do I stop it get on the I'm gonna have to wrap up
the cables as well raid she be already you lovely woman and get some food the
question why are women strongy so desperate to give weird kinks like I
open many doors and I never judge I wish to fulfill all fantasy your deep dark
things I strongy how about you send your nips to me and I'll and I'll tell you
how fast I ain't it's a blur to be fair it's a blur to be fair hey most these
will just move on if they think there's a dog there mmm strong he's a dungeon
master put up a sign saying beware wife if she's a yet bro you get targeted for
your figurine collection but like actual figurines not codeword figurines you
know she opens many doors this one happens to be the bathroom door no cuz
it's true right you gotta put them very believe that was a good one and then
ah ha ha ha laugh track so we're not into the darkness without a ghost stick
our only goal is the ink keep in game if you stop in king we can't see you okay
I'm gonna read it into sheepsters are you guys gonna be okay I know this is
rather on the short side I'm gonna take a big massive fucking job a and then
I'm gonna boot up the Kingsman in a membership stream
I'm not even kidding I'm fighting with King Kong finger right now I'm prairie
dog in I'm fucking fighting for my life okay finally found a place nearby that
are you gonna try it corn please try it I warn you though have it cold do not
have it room temperature are you gonna regret that decision I'm fairly help me
really help you need to you need to push down on my tummy to help me see you so
you actually had the loaf of bread all along you use the perfect now I'm so
inappropriate I've got can I am blue right now you ordered it off Amazon
Rievelin can't wait until it's Rabi burns in November I'm blue Scottish
girder juice girder she's baking a sorrow perfectly appropriate okay I'm
redirecting to sheepsters and then I'm gonna give me a few minutes you know
need this bad boy to cook a bit get out of me and then I must start up the
Kingsman so I hope you have it on the available streaming platform to watch
Kingsman together on the available streaming platform at your disposal you
did download you did access it right well got the Queen Kingsman yeah right
redirect into sheepsters confirmed we love she be little we're gonna redirect
into she be I love you refunds I'm sorry this was so short however you have me
for call of the lamb which is very big game I don't know how quick we're gonna
finish it but we'll get there but thank you for hanging out on me literally and
metaphorically and physically and all those a billy billy billy billy a shimmy
shimmy yeah shimmy yeah shimmy yeah drink swalla okay see you later
alligators in a wild crocodile and if not Kingsman after I take it will be love
you I'm sorry I'm so disgusting okay goodbye how many slides I ain't got 19
Slight
See you very shortly